hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to well a
sequel month is winding down to a close
we realized there are some good sequels
out there but there's a lot more bad
ones what is that after all the movie
prior had to start from nothing and win
people over you could argue sequels have
more of an advantage
it starts from something that people are
already familiar with and enjoyed so
technically that should mean there's a
greater chance the film will connect
with people because it already has in
the last one yet time after time we get
dud after does why does this happen so
often well I may be an old-fashioned
critic but I believe it comes down to
four specific failures the first one is
too much repeating there are certainly
some things we expected seeing a sequel
usually involving past characters or
similar themes a move however people
want the story to continue not be retold
to them a lot of folks want to see a
character or a story they've grown
attached to evolve the reason for this
is because they see something of
themselves in the character and they
don't want to just see themselves doing
the same thing over and over
movies like home alone to hang over to
and the transformer films get a bad
reputation because there's little to no
differences we do want to see these
characters again doing similar things in
the previous film but not the exact same
thing just changing the location or
adding one or two different elements
doesn't make it a grander experience
filmmakers often think that something
bigger
must be newer and it's not it's just
bigger Kevin being alone in the house
fighting off burglars is funny and
original doing the exact same situation
just in New York is the exact same
situation except in New York both this
film and hangover 2 are so guilty of
this that they constantly make
references by reminding you that they
already did it it happened again
we get the joke that the situation it's
so crazy it can't possibly happen again
yet of course it does but to have a
whole movie dedicated to that idea isn't
enough to hold our interest lost world
US Marshal speed - these are just a few
that fall victim to doing the exact same
thing just in a different location and
none of them are usually seen as fitting
sequels but most of these films were
made relatively clucked to each other
which brings us to our next big failure
letting too much time pass we've seen
what happens when a film can be rushed
out too fast but sometimes waiting too
long can be just as bad now don't get me
wrong sometimes waiting is good a
director as an actor can improve their
craft new ideas can bubble and a fanbase
can grow but most of the time the exact
opposite happens a directors talent
fades the ideas don't keep updated and
an audience can either grow tired of an
idea or become too obsessed take two
giants like Star Wars and Indiana Jones
- classic filmmakers return to their
groundbreaking franchises after years
and years of venturing into other genres
time away obviously created a disconnect
with their fan bases as most people
didn't get into any of these sequel
complaints of too much CGI poorly
written dialogue and focus in the wrong
areas seem to be major complaints for
these films movies like Godfather 3 and
Blues Brothers also fit into this
category
the original filmmakers return for one
last hurrah but nobody has for that one
last hoorah the last film we left off on
was fine
no improvements or additions necessary
because they let so much time passed
they both move slower lacking energy and
passion that the previous installment
had possibly from the very real fact
that people just got older the directors
writers and actors many performers can
get better with age but as with most
people age can slow you down very easily
and not keep you open to what's new and
also appealing films like Zorro - clerks
- and Terminator Genisys all has those
problems by the time the follow-up came
around nobody had the excitement to be
sucked into the same cast or creative
team reunited which I guess ties into
the next big failure not understanding
the sort
material we've seen this happen a lot
with a Batman movie constantly going
from award-winning game changers to
laughably lame misfires the creative
team for Dark Knight Rises MMB Superman
and especially the Schumacher Batman
films often miss what we like to see
with one of the most treasured
superheroes of all time sometimes they
focus too much on shows other times they
focus too much on blowing people away
and recently they focus too much on
Batman blowing people away but while
these films did still had some crowds
who will defend them films like some of
the masks Blair Witch 2 and Exorcist -
do not these are all movies they
attempted to give a sequel that in some
way tied into the original but
completely missed what it was about the
original that grabbed people some of the
math tried to be too ugly and obnoxious
Blair Witch 2 tried to be too
complicated and weird even the director
of Exorcist who admitted he didn't like
the original that much um is that such a
good choice for someone to direct a
follow-up to one of the most popular
horror films of all time films like
Wolverine or the Matrix sequels also
didn't connect well with their fan bases
claiming they were too different from
the original that they loved oftentimes
Eva tried to do too much or too little
either throwing a ton of story and
characters at us or not enough for us to
make any kind of connection and not such
a big shocker absolutely none of these
films I listed make any goddamn sense
but probably the biggest problem that
most people don't live doesn't even have
anything to do with watching the film it
has to do with making the film not
having enough time even if there's a
long gap in between making movies most
films are still bound with a due date
there are exceptions with film going
over budget and over time but the fact
remains it also has to come out at a
certain point often you don't have
enough time to find the appropriate
actor or enough time to convince someone
of the actor who would be better for the
role commonly a location can only be
used for a certain number of days or
hours
meaning not everything can be shot as
intended other times there just aren't
enough head screenings to figure out
what to fix before the release date or
time to go back and make the changes
needed a movie can even come out at the
exact wrong
it's a wonderful light bombed at the box
office because it didn't come out around
Christmas
UHF despite previews going fantastically
came out during the biggest blockbuster
summer in years since city - despite of
being just as cool as the first simply
waited too damn long to keep the energy
up sacrifices always have to be made
when making a film because of time
sometimes those sacrifices work out in
the long run but other times there's
just not enough to convince someone what
a film does or doesn't need perhaps
there are more elements that go into
making a bad sequel but these are the
four that stand out the most the good
news though is that these are the
downsides to making bad sequels then the
opposite must be true of making great
sequels
if repetition is too much new material
can be made if a film comes out at the
wrong times on the right time must also
be available if the essence of an idea
is missed and somebody can recognize and
fix it and if someone's not willing to
give enough time there's someone out
there who's willing to give more than
enough time sadly it's easier to destroy
that is to create but creation is what
we value and often reward more it takes
more effort because it's difficult to do
does we remember and respect them more
because they delight in surprises maybe
it's good that there's more bad people
than good because if we had more good
ones we be spoiled we want to appreciate
the hard work of the good ones nor
praise them when they blow us away with
their imagination restraint and
ingenuity are we ever going to get more
good sequels than bed probably not but
honestly that might be the perfect way
to have it if we always knew the next
one was going to be good then there
never be any surprises in the next part
of our thrilling story I'm under statue
critic I remember so you don't have
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
National Alliance to End Homelessness
this is the leading voice on federal
homelessness policy from advocating to
improve federal policy to analyzing
enacted and proposed legislation the
Alliance works collaboratively with
public private and nonprofit partners to
develop analyze and advocate for policy
solutions to homelessness this
organization provides capacity-building
assistance to help communities turn
policy solution and proven best
practices into viable on-the-ground
programs they provide communities across
the country with the best practices how
to do kits and technical assistance
training to help them implement
solutions develop through policy
research and practice if you go to their
site or their YouTube channel you can
not only see all the people that are
helped out through this but you can see
all the various ways and strategies that
they're using to stop homelessness to
make it so that it's not a problem
anymore this is a serious issue that
faces so many individuals and families
and you can help them get back on their
feet and live the life that they deserve
definitely check them out and see how
you can help
you